when you did something like the Super
Bowl oh my God is so nervous you were
nervous even though you're Madonna and
you've you you should yeah but that's
because it's live TV and the it was so
complicated to put that show together
you have eight minutes to build the
stage in the middle of the stadium you
know during halftime right and the NFL
hires locals to do that okay so you have
locals building your stage all right so
like and you have a lot of crazy things
happening you say it's like oh my God
what if they put it together right what
if it like starts to break down what do
the things don't work like out of your
hands every so out of control elements
out of control yeah so out of control
but you know live TV is is is crazy
anyways doing things on TV you know
whatever happens happens you gotta roll
with it so would you be nervous doing
Saturday Night Live because it's live
and you can't control the performance in
terms of if it goes out on the air and
things grow up yeah but I have done
Saturday but the thing is at least
Saturday Night Live is like there's a
joke element to it it's funny you know
when you're doing Super Bowls serious
the whole world is watching and you
better not mess up that's all there is
to it and there's a lot of like crazy
like like I said live elements you don't
get a lot of rehearse time
eight minutes to put the stage up and
then you would you have 12 I got 12
minutes and 47 seconds they gave me 47
seconds extra to be fabulous that'd be
great yeah to put on The Greatest Show
on Earth and you know after that
performance the world is going to
evaluate you right yeah and even after
all your accomplishments you sit there
and you go holy [__] yeah they're
criticizing they're still giving me
report cards yeah I still get a report
card honestly I was really only
concerned with my performance and if
everything that I set out to do I did
and I did it well and I was so relieved
when it was over with that I went to my
locker room lay down on the floor and
cried just because I got through it and
I knew that everything went off without
a hitch
foreign